ينضم الينا الان من بيروت فيصل عبد الساتر
الكاتب والمحلل السياسي اللبناني اهلا
وسهلا بك سيد عبد الساتر اي تداعيات
تتوقعها لبنانيا بعد هذا
الاختيار اولا مساء الخير لك ولكل
المشاهدين شكرا لهذه الاستضافه وطبعا
التعازي كل التعازي لقياده حركه المقاومه
الاسلاميه حماس والى كل الفلسطينيين والى
كل اللبنانيين الى كل حركات المقاومه بهذا
الاستشهاد ل هذا القائد الكبير صالح
العاروري الذي ارتحل وارتقى شهيدا عشيه
ذكرى استشهاد سليماني وابي مهدي المهندس
وهو كان الاقرب اليهما على مدار السنوات
الماضيه اي امر يعني هذا الاغتيال لبنانيا
انا اعتقد ان الامر اوسع من لبناني وهو
اكبر بكثير من ان يكون معنيا به فقط
الشارع اللبناني او المقاومه في لبنان او
الساحه اللبنانيه هذا استهداف لقائد كبير
في حركه المقاومه الاسلاميه حماس هذا
استهداف لراس من رؤوس المقاومه المسؤولين
الاساسيين عن عمليه طوفان الاقصى وكل
الساحه الفلسطينيه وهو المنسق ما بين
الساحه اللبنانيه والساحه الفلسطينيه
واكثر من من ساحه وبالتالي المعني به كل
هذه الساحات مجتمعه ثانيا المعني به ايضا
هذا الذي نسميه مجازا المجتمع الدولي الذي
يجب ايضا ان ينظر الى ما يقوم به العدو
الاسرائيلي من ارتكاب للجرائم والاغتيالات
الموصوفه سواء في سوريا او في لبنان او في
اي مكان فضلا عن عدوانه البربري والهمجي
داخل قطاع غزه والضفه الغربيه والمستمر
منذ ثلاثه اشهر دون ان يتحرك هذا المجتمع
الدولي ويلزم الجانب الاسرائيلي ولو بوقف
لاطلاق النار ووقف للعدوان
هذه رساله لمن يعنيهم الامر بان يعلموا
بان هذا العدو الاسرائيلي ليس في اجندته
وقاموس سوى الاغتيالات والقتل والغدر كما
فعل اليوم في هذا الاستهداف الخطير ثانيا
ان هذا الاغتيال له دلالات خطيره وخطيره
جدا لان الشعار المرفوع من قبل حزب الله
سابقا من قبل الامين العام لحزب الله ان
اي استهداف او اي اغتيال للبناني او
فلسطيني او سوري او اي جنسيه من الجنسيات
داخل الاراضي اللبنانيه هو اعتداء
واستهداف على لبنان وعلى حزب الله على وجه
الخصوص